why do cats live longer than dogs this
is really a question about lifespan why
do things die when they do here's what
we know large animals like elephants and
whales tend to live longer than small
animals like mice and fruit flies one
theory is that larger animals are less
likely to be preyed upon so over
evolutionary time they've invested
resources and harder bodies that can
withstand the test of time small animals
must live life in fast-forward so they
can reproduce quickly before they die
but in cats and dogs the size trend is
reversed with cats giving an average of
15 years while dogs with only about 12
just like whales and elephants the
ancestors of cats may have been better
at avoiding predators than those of dogs
small dogs meanwhile tend to live longer
than big ones sometimes twice as long
here evolution isn't at work but more
likely growth factors that may limit
lifespan or larger dogs growing so fast
that they have jerry-built bodies still
both cats and dogs are living longer
than ever before thanks to healthy diets
and improved veterinary care well our
pets in one day live as long as we do
unlikely but hopefully we can continue
to add more good years to their lives
you